alright Michelle is with us in Nevada hi
Michelle welcome to Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave so we are on baby step number 2 and
I'm wondering if I can quit my part-time
job okay how much do you make on your
part-time job 300 a week on average okay
how much debt do you have knocked out of
your house
doctor this month it'll be down to 2600
what's your husband like 93 a year we
have four kids and our two youngest
they're girls they're nine and 11 and I
normally work on the weekends and
they've been saying that they want to
spend more time with me so it's been
weighing on my heart well the numbers
say that you the work that you're doing
on the weekends is not moving the needle
much on the getting out of that part
your husband makes 93 and you make 12
hundred bucks yeah so I mean if you were
making twelve thousand bucks I guess we
could think about you know their little
hearts being having a little weight on
them but you know I it's not it's not
that big a deal right no I'm just
wondering if I should wait till January
or and get through this kind of busy
next few months that we've got gearing
up in my line of work or if I could just
quit now and enjoy the holidays with my
family well you can do whatever you want
to you're an adult I mean you guys get
to decide it here's the thing every
dollar you make that anybody makes in
this household clears up the debt you
only have twenty six hundred dollars in
debt left and your household income if
you quit is ninety three thousand
dollars did I understand that right yes
okay and so I don't want you I don't
want be disrespectful but mathematically
speaking your part time jobs are
relevant math agree does that make sense
yes it does I've just been working in
this field of work for 24
and so I'm so used to working that I
think that plays into it a little bit to
the fact that I would quit and just be
at home yeah but you told me two
different times two different ways that
this was a heaviness on you like you
said I'd really like to enjoy the
holidays and then you said it's been
weighing heavy on my heart that my kids
are griping about me being at work right
yeah okay and so I think that outweighs
any loyalty or obligation you've got to
you've been in this business for a long
time or whatever now again if you're
making $12,000 a month
everybody can stop whining and you can
tough it out till January
right but you're not you're making 1,200
bucks and in in the and if you 1,200
bucks was your only income you'd have to
tough it out but as a portion of your
household income it's a very very small
portion of your household income and
that's not being disrespectful to you or
even know what you're doing it's just a
math observation so if I were you just
listening to your the words that you're
using to describe this I think you
desperately want to quit I do
then quit okay and take it and take a
bunch of crap that y'all have been doing
lifestyle-wise around your house out of
the budget cook from scratch and coupon
and let's put the kids on consignment
sell clothes and let's get these debt
cleaned up and get that emergency fund
funded and you become a home economist
while you're at home with these kids but
but if you want to quit it's not again
it's not irresponsible in your situation